treadle she's a little [ __ ] there you go
there's your interview run Bibles
where's your party [ __ ] now yeah
that's a table as well
Santa be right wall snacks all right
nice to meet you all right
I'm not what is it defining moment in
your career
the comeback losing all the weight
coming back from mental health problems
10 stone weight loss getting back to the
top of the tree I think for me is gotta
be one thing he's scrolling the girl at
Wembley in 2008 yeah I played for a hall
setting my on town club against Bristol
see I was there a nine year old and I
scored an affair now a minute
and when you scored that goal what
happened we got we got promoted to the
Premier League so yeah it was a massive
achievement for me being a local boy
play hold on it's question what is your
favorite sex position
I mean wishes in the room I can tell you
what mental health issues depression
lose a map my father to know was my best
mate what messed me up was that I do I
had a row with my dad in in four or five
months way and 41 years of my life had
never other rel with him then that fab
mum see he passed away I than that suck
so I blame myself I blame myself and I
did do suffered a lot of anxiety and it
scares me he scared me frightening it
made me anxious
yeah for sure my anxiety depression
bipolar disorder probably every other
disorder I can go but I'm not doing bad
them really I'm like I think most people
are the same feelings don't they of of
worthlessness no wanting to live can't
do anything right every day it's a great
day and nothing's worth living for you
don't want to continue but when you've
been at the top of your game like that
and then all of a sudden it comes
crashing down I felt as though my form
never ran you know people didn't want to
share out fear him when he bulged him on
the speeds here but when he was winning
when he was beating critical people like
that and
we must remain in the good place ballot
no no I was totally depressed going into
that fight as you totally depressed but
I always had a goal to beat coach come
become a champion so I used to put it to
the back of my mind but I had a couple
of odd odd times all the way through
what do you know about depression when
you when you were growing up good
question
I didn't know anything about depression
growing up me I didn't understand it I
didn't know what it was the following
was just mood swings my father's just in
a bad mood sometimes and guess worse and
worse whereas the book I didn't have any
education at all no even as a teenager
as a young boy hmm
I've always suffered with yeah
depression I witnessed my mum trying to
take her own life so I didn't have any
education at all and as I got older it
was always in the back of my mind but I
was always very scared to come out and
tell people yeah every manager used to
said to me if you play well the team
play well and that's a massive pressure
on you I'd be out the back and ye gain
all the life from solid [ __ ] Jess
room today just I'd wake up in that sort
but I didn't know why it was you can
have a cloak so I was that I was too
young
didn't I tell last stages of my life
when when I would say it could have gone
wrong I can't remember it being a
certain incident where a certain trauma
or something that started it all so I've
suffered for depression all my life so
it's not a single thing that I can point
a finger to I think I must have been
born with him just grab the depression
into words two words
heavy [ __ ] [ __ ] awful is there a
stigma around mental health in
professional sport I think it was a lot
of footballers all coming out and
telling their problems yeah
you know I remember god bless him you
know a garish speedo passed away and he
was a good you know I'll call a book and
you Gary and I tried to do what he did
chart set me on life which I'm not proud
of some what's all of the kids I was fed
up of hurting people my wife my children
her my dad my mom was upset my brother
was upset and I thought if I'm not here
anymore
I can say there buddy I think being a
sportsman did did help me I had a drive
had a goal to achieve so I used to put
it all to me back in my mind but when
that goal was achieved then had nothing
to look forward to then it all come
flooding I had a mental breakdown right
well so yeah it helped me and then when
it was elder how did your family feel
about that because my family was like
fuming that I never said anything do you
know what it was none of my family
understood it at all that as far as
attention seeking and Riya yeah being a
little early so they used to say my
name's got it all he's never happy he's
always upset he's always in a bad mood
and he was like nobody understood so
everyone's like to pull yourself
together man what's up we're everyone
there's a lot people out there more
worse off than you and that's totally
the wrong stuff you want to win there
were people occurs and the thing that
everything is rising again you have not
got as much money as you've got now kiss
me ex-wife took a little bit for so
people said there's money Mac you're
happy
well I had money boy didn't make me
happy nor me as a person then you you
you make different judgments you know
yeah sure that's how I feel I know you
hundred percent same I think with a lot
more high-profile professionals in
sports coming out talking about it it's
much is to stick more almost and you get
late I listen to your clip do not to
listen to you have a wet jump in the
world and all of a sudden like you're
telling people the problems that you add
you know and you made me cry
and that's bad me on so you'll help me
good man
do you think it's possible to cure
mental health problems it's a tough
question
it's of grad or not well I'm not a
rocket scientist so I can do your deafen
and support from my experience I don't
think mental problems can be cured I
think it can be managed to maintain yeah
yeah you never go away yeah because I've
been happy for a period of time and then
for no apparent reason I would go back
being sad again yeah I don't think they
can be cured totally but there
definitely can be managed to maintained
what I learned very quickly is what
mistake therapist told me if you down
dog well for doing I want classes an
alcoholic those clusters I'll called
your payment so I could have a drink if
I want any trouble drink yeah and I was
never classed as an alcoholic
I was just classed as a devil for the
drink well there you got it but I
thought that I thought the drink was
helping me yeah cuz I just want I didn't
want to be Nam me on do you know you
need to focus you need the focus from
one liter for Ali true you know and I
try having that focus getting a sweat on
and going in the gym and doing so we're
gonna do it are you what and then you I
can't be without it yeah as well at 6
o'clock at least imagine just mad you
know I'm the same exactly the same I've
got a well I got to go to that gym every
day I'll go for a be with the boys no
problem yeah why aren't go for two weeks
before yeah yeah I'll go for five or six
but I was a bit and I'll go on yeah
because I know I'm gonna go back to the
gym tomorrow morning I'm gonna get back
flat Alex what is the thing you regret
most from your periods of mental health
crisis there's been a lot of things up
and good and bad and life's too short
for regrets because if I spent my life
looking backwards and we never move
forward so I concentrate on the future
and I concentrate on today I live for
today because we're not promised
tomorrow like you said your dad passed
away from a heart attack
like a few weeks ago my uncle went for a
Sunday dinner drops down dead 53 year
old attack he didn't think he was gonna
die going to throw Sunday - how did that
affect you it was terrible was close to
me uncle we said well all the time
getting Epistle all the time
hmm and it was a top fella but you just
don't think they're gonna be dead
actually so we can't concentrate on the
past you're gonna live for today not
special yeah yeah and don't get me wrong
you have good days and bad days horse
got a new partner now and and she says
you know if you've got a problem tell me
you know I'm in one on my brother or me
best mate this is another mental health
question I'm gonna shred it I swear to
God I better not be this is this is us
this is a fully station this is not a
station for gloom and doom is it do you
think your sport doesn't off to support
our fleets for mental health a for did
your upbringing make it default blood
bibles where's your [ __ ] now right
what's next
I've got two different offs here so with
your experiences in mental health how do
you think it helped people and coming
out and speaking about it being honest
with yourself yeah don't be scared to
tell you me a job scared to tell your
wife if we can come out and be honest
with ourselves
yeah for sure they're just a lot of wax
in the factory say for example you know
they're going well Tyson Fury came out
that night and said that he's had
problems now will probably go on to his
wife or his mum or dad away saying
listen Albert I'm strong with well if
anybody's out there well there will be a
lot of people out there suffering yeah
the best advice I can give anybody seek
medical advice immediately uncle
come open about it because I wish I
would have I've talked about it a lot
earlier than I did because I would have
got better sooner and I had to have a
mental breakdown before I could recover
and get better again until I can admit
to myself well for me I I trained a lot
and that's my medicine yeah my medicine
is going up live in a clean healthy life
and flat out training whatever the
doctors tell you to do
listen because yeah you can't you won't
go to a Tomica for advice on mental
health EXO you got sources for courses
as I mean the sooner you open up so you
can start recovery mm-hmm
deal as you met nice trailer that was a
top interview
[Music]
you